this week on quad Riga Ukraine sliding
into civil war battles on the streets of
Kiev between police and protesters some
of whom have been killed this is the
worst civil unrest in Ukraine since
anti-government demonstrations began two
months ago the opposition and government
blame each other for the violence
resident Viktor Yanukovych says the
state is under attack he has offered to
hold talks with the opposition but the
government has also tightened
restrictions on demonstrators opposition
leader Vitali Klitschko says the
president is not interested in dialogue
and has called on Ukrainians to come to
Kiev to join in the protests can further
escalation be avoided your host this
week Melinda crane hello and welcome to
quadriga could Ukraine be sliding toward
civil war what role can Europe Russia
and the US play those are some of the
things we want to talk about today on
quadriga with three guests who've been
following the situation in Ukraine very
closely I'm very pleased to welcome me
shouts Dermer he's the senior
correspondent at the German daily debate
he's a renowned historian and has
written extensively on Russia and on
Eastern Europe and it's a pleasure to
have with us demetriou can you ski he's
an editor for Deutsche Welle Ukrainian
service and himself is from Ukraine he
previously worked with the BBC and has
written numerous investigative articles
that dealt with exposing corruption and
organ trafficking and we're glad to see
cata gina's stop woza she is of Polish
origin she's a former head of the
Eastern European department at the
German Council on Foreign Relations and
now teaches at the University of
Southern Denmark a warm welcome to all
of you let's first start out with an
update on where things stand now
Demetriou the opposition leaders met
yesterday with President Yanukovych and
came out of that meeting with some very
strong remarks and ultimatums references
to bullets in the head and attacks that
almost sounded as if the country is
heading
towards Civil War what do you think well
i think that the situation in Ukraine is
really severe I don't think we have
witnessed anything like that in a past
22 years since Ukraine has regained its
independence in 1991 I do believe that
there were some red lines that were
crossed during this latest wave of
protests and the violence the excessive
use of force that we had seen definitely
shows us that things might escalate even
worse since today we have first death
according to some estimates there were
three people that were killed by the
government forces according to some
other I estimates this 15 people in any
case this is something that Ukraine
still has to fully understand the people
has fully to fully understand what has
happened there I think that the country
is still in shock you can see it from
from the news bulletins you can see it
affiliate brother when you talk to
people I've been talking to some of my
friends and colleagues war in Ukraine
the country's simply shocked because we
were not or Ukraine was not prepared for
that kind of round Cardenas top woza as
I mentioned the President did meet with
the opposition leaders how genuine do
you think is this offer of dialogue do
you think there's really room for
flexibility in his eyes I don't think so
not now because there's no really plan
how to do the opposition and it's not
possible to talk about one opposition in
the crane but that I say the opposition
doesn't really have a plan what to do
and the position doesn't really play in
a rule for the president for Yanukovych
so there's like him why should they be
important why should they debate each
other and Yanukovych is waiting still
waiting what will happen until he will
ask Russia you will ask put in to help
him and in my opinion
there will be more violence first and
after that the opposition will be
breaking down so the dialogue doesn't
really function for the moment and in my
opinion will not work in the future we
shall storm how much of a threat is the
situation in Ukraine for Europe for
Germany how concerned are you how
worried should people here be I think
this is on the scale of desert possible
disasters this is very high and anything
can happen and the title of our meeting
here Luke rain heading towards Civil War
maybe even heading further the this
piece of land the blood lands the
so-called has a great tradition of being
divided trampled upon treated badly and
not being able to help itself so i think
that the European Union stumbled into
something they didn't understand they
raised hopes that they couldn't fulfill
and they did that by offering Ukraine
and association agreement yes I think
that was the right thing to do but it
would have required much more a much
more sensitive approach it sounds in
Brussels it sounds awkward and shocking
when you say do you understand the
Russian position in all of this Russia
is a big player and Russia s by no means
resigned itself of Putin's Russia has
not resigned itself to being a minor
player on the European stage I remember
20 years ago when Putin was still in st.
Petersburg we had a meeting back at
office place guys around 30 people from
all over the world and it was the debate
was on Russia's future borders 94 and
there was this
unknown young man sitting next to
burgermeister sup sup Chuck and he
suddenly exploded although normally we
talked they're very modestly and
moderately and said Russia's borders are
untenable and there are 25 million
Russians living on the wrong side of the
bow of the border and their future for
us is a question of war and peace I've
never forgotten I want to come back to
the got2b for poutine yes I want to come
back to the geopolitical situation but
let's stay just a longer a bit longer
with the question of exactly what's
happening right now on the ground I
asked about how much flexibility
President Yanukovych really would show
in terms of negotiations with opposition
leaders let's take a brief look at the
other side Demetriou county of ski how
much influence do those opposition
leaders actually have over the
protesters on the street well i think i
would not exaggerate if i may say that
the opposition leaders and there are
three of them which also causes a huge
problem for the crowds as they would
like to see one leader who is leading
the opposition who has the answers who
is charismatic that all we actually do
not see because there are three people
that have different backgrounds that
have different approaches somewhat
different ideology as well and also we
should not forget that just what those
three people stand for if you would give
us a very very brief a nutshell as well
talking briefly arm probably one of the
most prominent opposition leaders is
Vitaly Klitschko famous boxer and
worldwide exactly and who turned into a
politician some years ago and since then
has gained quite a lot of respect but
not much of the influence we cannot say
that he totally hit that he turned into
you should go to so to say in his first
and good days when he was really leading
the crowds this we had not witnessed up
until now the second leader is arseniy
yatsenyuk mmm who took over so to save
Timoshenko place after she was put into
jail by the Yanukovych authorities
he is kind of a centrist more right
oriented politician that also has his
presidential ambitions like all three of
them basically but there's a lot of
criticism towards similar even cartoons
made about him so not always he's taken
seriously although he really tries to
you and the third leader is electronic
book who represents a far-right Svoboda
Freedom Party movement was very
nationalist with a stronghold in West
Ukraine although elsewhere we have to
say that the support for the water party
in the last few years had also witnessed
a very interesting rise also in the
central parts and you know of Ukraine
and also the capital Kiev so basically
those are three people who are leading
Ukrainian opposition now and causing a
lot of problems within the crowds who
would like to see them really putting
forward one candidate is instead of
three but of course a very interesting
point to mention that it's not only
those parties who are present there at
Maidan and Khrushchev School Street
there are also some autonomous protests
who are not controlled by any force for
instance private sector the right sector
these are all so far far-right
nationalist or radicals who are present
there and they are not controlled
they're not basically a submitted to any
kind of control from from the political
leaders so let's take it what about the
ukrainian diaspora and canada and other
places well ukrainian Jasper has been
playing a very important role generally
I mean since the beginning of the 90s
they've been very actively involved in
mediating in negotiating in being
present in the last way of what we
definitely know for sure that the
Ukrainian diaspora in the United States
has been actively involved in
negotiations that took place in the
Ukrainian Senate there were hearings
just last week the question of sanctions
targeted sanctions the crane against the
Ukrainian authorities were debated there
they were organized and help with the
representatives of Ukrainian Jasper so
they are they have not retreated such as
a they are they are they are present and
also Ukrainian Jasper even here in
Germany and elsewhere were staging huge
protests and huge rallies in support of
Ukraine's pro-european movement in the
past two months Cartagena stock was it
the violence that broke out at the
beginning of this week the violence that
at least gave the security services the
pretext of needing to go in where did
that violence come from some people are
saying that the government itself may
have bussed in from elsewhere radical
violent young people perhaps paid them
off are there real indications of that
not really but different explanations
and different analysis and some analysts
say that the government is responsible
for the violence our door experts say
that this is the opposition and this is
of course what the crying and government
says as well as the opposition is
responsible for the violence and
interesting because what's the Russian
point of view a point of view of Russian
President Putin and Russian Foreign
Minister in their opinion Western Europe
is responsible for the violence and
Western Europe European Union why
because worse than European countries
supported the Ukrainian opposition
supported not on in political speeches
but also participating through their
participation at the Maidan together
with the opposition drawing for us
Western Europeans freedom and the
freedom of movement freedom of speech
it's very important and this is why we
support this movement in the crane and
now this is a good argument for the
Russian side to say you are responsible
for what's happening now nuclear indeed
it was the former German Foreign
Minister Guido vez de vela who traveled
to Kiev and stood with the
testers at the beginning of the first
round of demonstrations in the fall of
2013 he apparently was the one the
Russian Foreign Minister met were meant
yes when he made these veiled remarks
about Western leaders standing in
solidarity was that a mistake on mr.
Vesta Bella's part on the part of the
German Foreign Minister of the time I'm
not a great admirer wasn't a great
admirer of the former German Foreign
Minister he missed out on the Egyptian
and Arab Spring he came late and was
criticized for that and then he / went
over the top once again and acted as if
he were an act an actor in the in the
drama and now he didn't want this time
he didn't want to be left out and this
was not coordinated I don't think it was
well advised because you pour oil into
fuel enters a wildfire which you don't
understand and I think in the in the big
picture you have to be very careful here
are forces at work from from history and
from great bitterness and there are
potentials which are difficult to
understand in the air-conditioned rooms
of Berlin or Brussels so I would have
advised send you a state secretary send
your parliamentary state secretary to
Kiev and keep keep in the background
it's not for us to really add to the
enormous trouble potential trouble
militant potential that is unleashed
here or is being in the process of being
unleashed I think we should keep in the
background and take an active role but
keep in the background and also talk to
the Russians so the Russians say that
Western leaders are held
to incite the protest and the violence
in Kiev and some in the West say that
mr. Yanukovych the president of Ukraine
is playing by the Russians playbook they
say that the laws that were passed
against freedom of assembly look an
awful lot like the same kind of laws
that were passed in Russia in the
response to the great demonstrations
there of 2011 2012 moreover they say
that the use of text messages this week
to scare the protesters also looks an
awful lot like techniques that have been
used in Russia is that right to me
trochowski yeah it is completely wrong i
would say that in many ways are the
ukrainian party of regions to who is
which is holding basically the power now
in the parliament who's they has the
biggest fraction there and to whom
basically the President Yanukovych as
well as prime ministers are of belong
they are trying to complicate sort of a
lot of those Russian kind of new house
how to crack down on protests and how to
deal with the protest movement and not
only we had seen also those horrible
kind of firm low proposals on the ban of
so-called propaganda of homosexual isn't
in towards minus so I think that their
role model remains Russia and I've just
been reading comments from the former
foreign minister of Germany mr. yushka
theisha who claims that Yanukovych in
fact was always kind of a Russian man
who always played who always played
those Russian cards i would like to
agree to that it didn't to subscribe
really to that point of view i do
believe that this whole extravaganza of
signing the agreement to North signing
the agreement was actually kind of a
play in order to win he yes exactly in
order to win the the best possible
conditions from Russia because it would
be impossible now to imagine Yanukovych
playing by European rules if he would
sign this agreement in November your
meaning your meaning that he was
essentially leading the Europeans on in
order to get the Russians to up the ante
in Russian the more money from
and not honor sorry not only support for
his political project but private
support we should not forget I would
like yeah i would like to remind our
viewers the fact that the son of
Yanukovych officially has turned into
billionaire in the past two or three
years whereas the the gap between rich
and poor in Ukraine remains remains
incredibly high and it's not only the
son of Yanukovych there's there's a new
term Familia called family exactly
senior or family in Ukrainian support
from Russia all those all those
oligarchs and all of those fellows of
ukrainian President and those in power
who have access to the money and what
kind of the money is that and how how is
it managed and where what are the
origins of this money is a big question
katarzyna struck was a let's remember
exactly how much money we're talking
about here 15 billion dollars in loans
that's what Russia promised Ukraine last
December now something I don't
understand President Yanukovych had
almost neutralized the protest movement
at that point when he got this huge
promise of Russian money in December the
protest movement appeared to be
dissipating why in the world did he take
the risk of pushing through these very
strict laws against protests against a
power of assembly the right to assemble
when things appear to be going well for
him he basically reactivated the protest
movement why would he have taken that
risk yeah because he so that the
opposition doesn't really give up yes
and of course the movement wasn't so
intensive as at the beginning can sure
when we analyze the situation two months
ago our analysis was that they will stop
in one month but we saw that their
protest yes still worth developing yes
they didn't come into the end so
Yanukovych had to decide something and
had to take a decision and to move
something country to come to the edge
and he knew of course that for the floor
for the sanction he will provoke crises
he will provoke a cow's very chaotic
situation and now he was waiting the
situation will become worse and in that
woman Putin we ask do you need my help
to really do something and to come to
the ancient this is why Yanukovych had
to change his strategy change his plans
to begin cows they my done and to get
Russian support vicious rumor the
worsening violence occurred on unity day
in Ukraine the day when Ukraine
celebrates the unity of West and East
that it achieved in 1919 how many more
unity days do you think Ukraine will be
celebrating you mean really unity days
or propaganda unity days propaganda is
there is in those parts of the world
long tradition of pretending a reality
that doesn't exist in the real reality
it's a Kafka a situation of course you
play games which are meant to present
your own identity and put the others the
enemies into a bad
light I don't think that is that is very
meaningful these things are ideological
tools and flags and I would like to come
back to the real situation and the real
situation seems to me can be described
in at least two if not more chess boards
there is the Ukrainian chess board and
then there is the Ukrainian Russian
chess board and the Yanukovych is not
just the puppet with which Putin is
playin around he has his own agenda we
and of course he plays off Brussels vs
Moscow and he has done that quite
successfully seen not from the point of
view of Ukraine and the Ukrainians but
seen from his own point of view from his
family from his friends his oligarchy so
again and then you have the big chess
board America Brussels Moscow and the
problem is that they are united only in
one point and that's the key role of
Yanukovych if he were to say today as of
tomorrow eight o'clock I'll be a
Democrat I listen to everybody we have a
round table put sit together like people
did in Poland for many years going
slowly while the outside world was
trying to be helpful not to be seen too
much neither the Russians wanted to
interfere nor did the West really
interfered was a standoff a very complex
chessboard again you have to you could
and at some stage we have to talk about
a way out and solution if there is one
and then you have to again sink in these
stress ports none of them you can ignore
mr. Sturmer some years ago demetriou can
you ski wrote about your country that
the question of its identity
where it belongs russia vs europe would
remain open for has been open for a very
long time and would remain open for many
years to come do you think that's right
and could you imagine your country
heading toward division well identity of
course is a kind of a painful issue for
Ukrainians but I wouldn't really share
they thought that this unity day or dare
that Ukrainian unity is a sort of
propaganda tool if you write on a
cross-country train in Ukraine that goes
all the way from live in the west of the
country up until Donetsk or Luhansk in
the very east of the country get to see
all kind of people getting in and
getting out from the train you get to
hear what what they think you get to
hear their thoughts they all United you
know there's a lot of unity there they
all fed up with corruption they all fit
up with economical problems they'll fit
up with a inability to seek and find
justice in courts or whatever else and
this is something that unites people
people after all they stayed the same
food they seemed pretty much the same
carols for same language sometimes Wow
of course language is is sort of a
painful and problematic issue but then
again look at Belgium they also face the
same problems but Belgium is still
United although there shortly there are
constantly talks but look at Switzerland
they have three languages and I think
there was of course there was a huge
failure in in what concerns cultural and
language policy in the past 20 years in
Ukraine but nevertheless we do see that
the children and the the youngsters
who've been already born during
Ukrainian independence in the past 20
years they tend to speak Ukrainian they
tend the the eastern air at the young
generation this spread in OV cranial end
which is much stronger than when I was
even a kid in central Ukraine in the 80s
so I wouldn't say those divisions we
shouldn't forget their old broads some
some of them of course are real as long
as Ukrainians do not speak about history
or politics they remain united as soon
as they start to speak there might be
some gaps there definitely but we have
to remember that those divisions a lot
of times are broad and imposed by the
politician stems
south on all kind of level exactly this
is a difference between people yes
educated well educated people in the
crane and there's no difference between
Western Eastern young Ukrainian a
buncher does not really a well-educated
with Western values political class in
the crane and this is the problem this
is why it's I theories but it is very
hard for him to get into power and
together yep let us now come to the
question of potential solutions to the
extent that there are any good ones and
take a look first of all at the role of
Europe the you EU foreign ministers have
issued a statement saying that they
stand by the need for political and
economic integration but many people are
questioning whether the ue you perhaps
misconstrued the situation in Ukraine
here's a look it was President
Yanukovych his desire to seek closer
ties with Russia and spurn the European
Union that sparked the protests in kiev
now Russian Foreign Minister Sergey
Lavrov says the situation in Ukraine is
spinning out of control he has urged
European governments not to interfere we
would prefer if our European colleagues
did not behave in such an arrogant
manner when it comes to the Ukrainian
crisis the city of wonder Cecil Gaines
can pretty soon but on the streets of
the capital protesters have been calling
for more European involvement many want
the EU to impose sanctions we call on
European deputies European politicians
European citizens we demand that they
not only declare European values but
also embody them in action we need your
help
your help in recent months the European
Union has repeatedly signaled support
for the opposition but how should a
react without further Fanning the flames
of conflict vicious rumor the foreign
ministers of the EU issued a statement
as I said but it was pretty thin stuff
has the EU abandoned Ukraine the EU has
got a shock when they learned that their
involvement through the association
agreement and the wherewithal the
association agreement of course was a
dog not too much more for the entry into
a long-term positive liberal democratic
environment sort of the west or central
european model and now the EU planners
strategists foreign paulo politicians
have learned that this is dangerous
stuff and they are a little shocked and
that goes beyond their brief and the
various countries in the EU also not
united on what to do so the foreign
policy weakness of the EU is manifested
here they they stumbled upon a big
problem by accident almost it looked
look we have since for the last 25 years
there was widening widening widening
without really giving a sword to the
wider implications the international
implications the the EU is convinced
that we are on the right side of history
that we represent the right values and
that every reasonable person and decent
person or to subscribe to what we are
doing well not so it's not enough to
tell the Russians you are old you come
from the 19th century you are thinking
in spheres of interest and leaving it at
that you have to somehow come to terms
with the reality that there is a big
Russia and that the big Russia
is very unset unhappy with the with the
present situation and poutine I'm not
sure about what what what Putin's
long-term strategy is but one strategy
is certainly one element of its strategy
is to rebuild a big sphere of influence
cuz we are now in a conflict with that
plan katarzyna stock was a your country
poland of course shares a border with
Ukraine and the claims that are made by
Russia in regard to eastern Ukraine
could certainly perhaps be made by
Poland in regard to Western Ukraine
namely that its friend brother neighbor
as the as the Russian ambassador here
recently said in regard to the east what
would Poland want to see the EU do right
now you're completely right for Poland
Ukraine is very important but first
point I think in this example of Maidan
and the crane shows us that we don't
really have a common European foreign
policy because of the different
interests and now Poland would like to
play completely different rule that for
example Germany so Germany tell us tell
us about that what would call it won't
register for Poland is grain above all
Western Ukraine because and now we have
to think about the map we have poll
intent we have Western Ukraine as direct
neighbor and two are talking when we are
talking about languages in the western
part of the crane the main language is
cranial and the second one is polish yes
sent after polish language the
Ukrainians say first let us try to talk
in polish and later on in Russian so you
see how important this direct
neighborhood a Polish cranial cranium
neighborhood really Center Poland would
like to influence more and more directly
than Germany France and other European
countries the democratization process in
the crane a Polish leaders polish
politicians
I say let us be more directly let us
support more opposition but of course
for us Western European we know how
difficult it is yes because we have to
do with a foreign policy so it's very
important they say polisher but it I
think will not really play a special
role because it's not possible to decide
this on a one nation how to support
democratization process in the other
country Demetriou can you have ski one
very concrete measure that some people
have been calling for sanctions would
they help to pacify the situation or
could they push President Yanukovych
right into Russian czar oh it is a very
question of Alicia I would say if we
look at the example of Belarus the
sanctions have been introduced there
since 2004 and actually we had not seen
a lot of changes there on the other hand
you know speaking about poland i just
remembered i was reading the other day
memoirs of former British Prime Minister
Margaret Thatcher who was described in
the situation in the early 80s after a
crackdown of Polish communist
governments against Allah darkness to
movement and she was very anxious she
writes that I felt led that the West
needs to respond somehow with sanctions
or with other measures but I wasn't sure
what kind of sanctions to do and of
course she was she was also seeking help
from from President Reagan and the US
had had their own policy so the
circumstances are different today but we
do see the problem of introducing
sanctions yet again some 30 years after
the solar darkness to crack down
happened I do believe that without
targeted sanctions and I would like to
emphasize targeted that would not target
the people because of course there are
some human issues involved corporate
issues business issues involved in
putting sanctions against the country
but targeted sanctions against those who
are responsible and still were not held
accountable for the use of
unproportional and extensive violence
against the
justice I think they must be introduced
and the question whether they will hurt
those in power those responsible i think
is positive because after all where do
they spend their holidays is it in
Siberia or is it here somewhere in
France Germany or Austria this is where
they are keeping their capital and there
is a lot of money if the sanctions if I
press all so on the road of other
country the US has apparently just
revoked visas of some members of the
political elite it's unclear at this
point exactly who they are but the US
did take that step my chest remember
when when we talk about the issue of
corruption among the elite in Ukraine
then one wonders whether the real
problem is that the EU simply didn't put
enough money on the table Robin
intervention rather than sanctions was
there a financial option here that the
EU didn't happen I wouldn't like to
speculate on the aspect of the EU sort
of moving a brown envelope in the
direction of some important and
influential members of the Ukrainian
government it cannot be done we are in a
way we are too decent and we are too
nice bad things happen in the west of
course but we cannot have an official
policy of corrupting buying foreign
governments it has to be done in a much
more subtle way and you you yes it can
be done and the association agreement
was of course not a corruption it was a
generous offer of a long-term positive
rebuilding strategy which is in the
interest of course of the the Ukrainian
people which is also in the interest of
the neighbors Poland and in the interest
of the rest of Europe a kind of it was
the nearest thing to what we always
refer to as a new Marshall Plan but as a
carrot it was not sufficient so what
about this sticks what kind of
deterrence what kind of 50 billion in
cash to mr. Yanukovych
and first child my suggestion was of
coordinating in cheek botella time when
you addictions would you favor say aye
even if they bring the EU into more
direct conflict with Russia um not
necessarily some there are some really
bad apples in the Ukraine and basket and
you can target them and make their life
a little more uncomfortable when they
come to the West not giving them visa
freezing their big accounts these things
have worked with Iran why shouldn't they
work with Ukraine and you in line you
could at least imagine that they're all
very close to God and are not concerned
with worldly things but Ukraine is very
much concerned with worldly things and
you want to cherish your ill-gotten gain
somewhere better than in Ukraine so I
think this makes people think but can it
has not very little to do with Russia
well on the other hand Russia however
has as you have all stressed a number of
times a very very strong interest in
what happens in Ukraine does that make a
difference here Cartagena would that
possibly undermine the effects of
sanctions oh yes of course it makes a
difference and you torture before that
it isn't clear what does Russia Russia I
really want and which role will asha
annually play i think it is clear russia
would like to get back crane like Russia
cocked back we can say Bella Russia
that's right not in political forum but
as a very close direct neighbor and
Russia would like to have a total
influence on the crane like it's the
case with Belarus and now politicians
and people in Belarus are very much
agree with this disruption player and so
what we forget in our analysis and
discussions as the many times that show
we are talking about democratic values
not only about the money but this is
water in
still doesn't play so big role in the
crania swen we talk about democratic
values and freedom and chair Ukrainian
politicians as a torch but what doesn't
mean yes we want financial support and
this make the difference between grain
and Poland 20 years ago yes Damita is
that the picture that we're heading
toward a Ukraine that falls back into
the Russian sphere of influence in the
same way that viola Ross has done and if
so are we seeing a return to something
like a division of Europe into spheres
of influence I think it is too
preliminary to say that after all the
struggle goes on in Ukrainian that's
exactly what the people in Ukraine or
the majority of very large amount of
people in Ukraine want to overturn
according to some opinion polls only
every 5th Ukrainian kind of agrees or
has a consent that the democracy will be
taken out from the country and instead
they will have some financial benefits
so basically only only twenty percent of
Ukrainians and most of them by the way
the picture is very clear it's always in
the east only every 50 crane ian is
actually ready to some kind of to make
compromises with democracy the majority
of people are not ready for that so I
don't think that we will see belarus
ification in the way of Ukraine if that
would happen we wouldn't even have those
protests that we are having now if the
if the Ukrainians would be so submissive
and would take this path without
struggling to overturn it one other
point that I would also like to make
regarding the diplomacy issues I think
that the you could have been a lot more
generous in its offer to Ukraine I'm not
sure it would own it would somehow
influence the sign in or association
agreement and we in Vilnius but on the
other hand it would take those arguments
away from Prime Minister zareff who's
been claiming that the U has not been
putting enough money he wouldn't have
this argument anymore and something also
that we have to remember like like we
already said Russia I will not give up
its political
ad against Ukraine it wants to suborn
Ukraine if it cannot buy Ukraine it will
try to get Ukraine in one way or another
last word tamesha storm amisha derma
where is the red line for Europe at what
point would it go into a direct
confrontation with Russia over this I
think in an ideal world we should start
now to go into a positive competition
with Russia for the soul and the
well-being and future of Ukraine in the
real world we are in for more trouble
and conflict thank you very much to all
of you for being with us today and
thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon
you